the Joe Rogan experience not necessarily
stone but beautiful meanwhile you walk
on stage and go [ __ ] me
these edibles I walk in here and go [ __ ]
me I didn't do my nails but you yank
these edibles I used to do all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] what do you mean
draw drug was well you [ __ ] yeah of
course well yeah well well you were
being born I was walking on York City
with John Belushi Oh knocking on your
door to get some blow I mean we were
good good friends we it's what you did
back then I believed that in the spirit
of music was think of it this way why do
you think they call booze spirits and
when you listen to your favorite song
you want to [ __ ] your wife hmm I think
that spirits you know wherever it takes
you whatever feeling it is whatever when
I went to Muscle Shoals I put my hand on
the wood I felt the room because I knew
that Little Richard stood right and [ __ ]
in front of me right all I gotta do is
close my eyes and go back in time for a
second if I you know what I did a song
with roots rock reggae play the funky
music and it was [ __ ] see I don't have a
long-term memory
who did that song come on help me play
that funky music white boy no roots rock
reggae um roots rock reggae who's up
who's the best reggae artist of all to
Bob Marley okay son calls me up and goes
you got to do the song I go in they put
in they put it on the two-inch tape the
oxide the old-fashioned two-inch tape
and I'm in there ready to sing right and
I'm they start rolling and I'm listening
I got I got everything turning up and I
hear Bob walk into the studio I hear the
drummer sit down on the drumset and his
stool squeaks any farts no but as he can
hear him pick up sticks you hear hear
the bass player [ __ ] around with his
bass and talking to Bob mind what you
[ __ ] will do feet how are you feeling
today Mon and I'm in the room with Bob
Marley so what is spirit if that's not
it I made them play that back again for
me because I just write close my eyes
and your
in the room with Bob mark with a
certainly something right when you hear
a song a great song from the past and
you get goosebumps and just feel it
inside of you something you get moved
but what does that have to do with booze
I think booze is called spirits because
it puts you in that place right foni
release mission releases inhibition so
some great truth serum isn't it it is
but is it false or is it just that it
just gets abused I think it's not false
exactly it makes you say things you wish
you didn't then you go I was lying
I'm only [ __ ] around well you could
be in love for a moment [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] nice
tell me you never done blow I've never
done blow ever known for drink either I
drink okay cool yeah when I was growing
up my friends cousins sold blow and I
saw disastrous results and I was scared
off of it when I was very young Wow good
then I had some friends that as I grew
older had blow problems so I never
touched it see you're one of them man no
no it's your Normie Normie in some ways
but I've done a lot of differently like
you said in that in your last that last
documentary just joking you are farthest
from the Normie
well some people it's smart that you
thought not to do that yeah it just
seems like one that I would like too
much yeah you know one of the reasons
why I never [ __ ] with speed either I'm
gonna feel like I'd be like now I can
get things done but you drink coffee
don't you
yeah but smiled the confident really
jack is [ __ ] mile this man is just
mild he what is it
Kemp chameleon which changes your
[ __ ] skin into another color this is
a cold brew coffee it's just coffee not
that it's not coffee it's called Lucky
Jack nitro cold brew coffee you might as
well just stick this in your arm I don't
think so
really yeah I mean I don't know because
I've never stuck anything like that in
my arm
neither have I I'm just saying that it's
not that it's it's pretty strong
actually it's probably not like what I
make in the morning is like
colder coffee I love Kona cross and I
fill that [ __ ] to the top it's so dark
that when you pour it you can't see
through the stream yeah that's when you
know you're going on Joe Rogan hmm and
gonna spew some [ __ ] some real [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] some hot lava hot lava
sir I'm Kona
so then so we did that so we did brown
sugar me and Nuno Bettencourt and we got
all the players from way back then the
horn sections got curls to sing it it's
just gonna be Bobby Womack sat in that
room and he did you know I used to love
you but it's all over now songs alright
that was that day Marvin Gaye I'm in
this room with all his tape so if you're
a musician you feel the vibes right if
you're comedic and you go to the Comi
store you feel like you're walking
around in placenta Laureate yeah there's
not a recording spot for comedians you
know you guys have a bunch of performing
spots but you also have recording spots
we only really have performing spots
yeah we record in those performance
buttons but I'm performing yeah let me
not go into mmm I just had these on last
night fixing the lyrics and when you
have them on you listening to the track
it's just it's something you can't
explain nobody understands that and it's
akin to tripping on acid it's akin to
being drunk and sucking face with a girl
making out whether it's akin to watching
your kids be born it's an elevated
experience its way elevated and if you
if you buy it and you push the top floor
like I do way past the penthouse boom
well I know you do it hmm that's why I'm
reading this off okay this is a day this
is a day this is what was a month well
whatever it is it's you and also you've
been doing this a long time this is like
a life what I mean the reason why you
don't have any memory it's because you
probably filled all your hard drive
space with crazy experiences well said
you know I have forgotten more than most
people could ever remember how could you
not well how the [ __ ] could you remember
everything you've ever done go talk to a
farmer about some [ __ ] that happened in
the 50s overall that was the day that
Carroll wouldn't give us milk they
remember well it's two things going on
here I'm surrounded by people that
always remind me that's good too you got
a good team yeah and sometimes I gotta
be on like live on The Tonight Show
write this thing I did was it with a
beautiful blonde Entertainment Tonight
I just watched it back I thought that's
the best interview I think I've ever
done because she looked me square in the
eye she was beautiful she asked just
right questions
and was just perfect
[Applause]